all right guys I'm Greg I'm John so so
many people requested this today just
drop first first into request is for
sure
DFK 220 on the trailer split to [ __ ]
King before we do that we did do the
whole talk about it on separate video
but wanted to give a quick mention a lot
of people a lot of subscribers have
suggested we start up one for a while
now especially after last week we did
star lineup because you guys kept
requesting it and you guys are so
supportive we started up a patreon
account we're not the most comfortable
with talking about something like a
patreon we've never done something like
this before but if you guys can go over
there and help support the channel if
you want to donate that'd be great
doesn't matter how small or how big
whatever you can donate would be
amazeballs like if anybody goes there
and donate something we will be so we
will be very very good yeah our first
person who donated already who just
found it was House Heisenberg shout out
to you mofo you're beautiful you are
view five bucks of what he's donate them
holy [ __ ] yeah five bucks it's amazing
Mariam Howard it doesn't matter yeah
he's amazing
anyway I looked like the honest trailer
for split this between the raised way to
ask for spoilers Thalia uh-huh I like
got nervous company
and we could not a number for apartment
from the director who exploded onto the
scene then went out like a hot fart
comes what might be and nights on Ilan's
greatest surprise yeah he's actually
kind of good again I did not see this I
made James McAvoy stars is a man with 24
split personalities in the same body but
get ready to see only about 85 which
kind of blend together I think I'm
talking to n still he'll teach a master
class and channeling a wide variety of
query child I'm one come to you creepy
Tim Gunn I'm gonna handprint with
newspaper headline and creepy mrs.
Doubtfire pretty fine and your hair as
they do a wonderful job explaining how
so many personalities can coexist in his
mind but ignore one big question how
does he always have the right clothes
new body changes does a heat a grandma
sweater in every room just in case no
walks Negra black circles around the
rest of the cast literal circles because
it's domestic there's just stand around
and wait to be eaten or lock themselves
into lockers or not run away when this
happens okay and run run and go run away
right now running you [ __ ] but don't
worry
fans of the old bachelor on because
he'll still be guilty of its trademarks
wide vacant staring wood and acting how
do you think and the worst dialogue this
side of the happening okay what health
conscious fast food prepared if you
originally solicit to buy these chicken
wings you so lovely
a minor suicidal gesture yep there's the
enzyme we all know in hey so prepare for
the dawn of a new Shimano songs in a
classroom it also works at the end hold
on
if you don't want to twist in the split
room you're gonna want to clear out for
this large okay I'll give you some time
to click away while we watch the win
from the happening Matt okay everyone
going he doesn't want the big twist
spoiled all right I'm in Philly it's a
secret is equal to unbreakable how cool
is that I'm looking at 17 years old made
by a different studio which most people
in the audience likely forgot about
there's no way you saw that coming now I
can't help wondering is it all connected
who knows could show up in the Shambhala
verse could we get a hold of Shamal
Avengers with a Kenzi stick and cypher
Raige nevermind
that would be terrible you're not on the
doghouse yet night man ah the O in my
cameo personality is 9 through 23 mr.
plinkus basement
beast mode activated and what it's like
to be a girl on the Internet
take off your shirt take off you should
connect it you check what will feel
rural enough you wanted Florida team to
use Kevin's full name and bring him
forward this guy isn't gonna be much of
a challenge to Bruce Willis he's got the
same weakness as Rumble still good they
may reward you for even more honest
trailers including rug won in Star Wars
story and the bad in aijalon movies
click the boxes above be careful not to
choke on your observations I only know
one true it's time for the Jedi Ahmed
frankly my dear I don't give a damn I
have a Senate red lorry yellow lorry red
lorry yellow lorry red lorry yellow
lorry red lorry yellow lorry red lorry
yellow lorry red lorry yellow lorry yeah
well good you're the elocution you know
that a movie is probably good when an
honest trailer is only four minutes long
yeah yeah when they only have a couple
grand they only have a couple of things
you could really say about the movie and
a couple of nits yeah there's a fern
area but this is nothing there's nothing
there we were like that's a major flaw
of the movie yes I do agree you know how
they're you know they're obviously
they're gonna bring up like oh and I
Chum once past bad work or not
well-received work yeah the visit was
cool split was amazing I still feel like
he needs one more really good film yeah
he's definitely back then you have to
travel is that chicken visit was fun and
unexpected but it's not like a movie or
people like this is terrific it's a
great book it was a refreshing comeback
because it wasn't too heavy and it
wasn't due like it was just it was just
right you know it was like oh [ __ ] I'm
really really keeping my appealed for
how he goes about whatever the third
thing oh yeah I mean I've got to be
careful with decision you don't get this
opportunity very from my understanding
he's gearing up to do you know the split
unbreakable crossover from Kevin and
David meeting each other officially
that's what his next ambition is and Ike
I wouldn't mind if he did one more film
first before he does that one that would
be kind of cool with me actually if he
just did one more film and then do your
crossover I'm actually with you on that
yeah kind of a 10 I mean I I feel that
way about most anything that'll become a
franchise but especially with at night
because because nothing would suck more
to have that movie be the one where it's
kind of
oh not that I think it would be I think
like the unbreakable universe he's made
two really good films inside of it so
like you know there's a lot that bodes
well for that but I would like to just
see him just make another mappers I know
I like the idea and the Momentum's we
talked about this in a separate video a
while ago connecting it to a breakable
and having Bruce Willis show up I
thought the idea was really cool the way
the scene was done I wasn't a big fan of
the execution of it seemed a little out
of place for me but connecting and
having Bruce Willis appear and all that
that was really cool to me and I think
it was really smart what he did to do it
that way like presented us with original
material but also you know sort of
remind fans who have kind of stuck
around with M night Shyamalan this whole
time and I think out of all his films
unbreakable has the biggest cult
following because there wasn't the most
financially successful out of like a lot
of his films but it is definitely about
the strong cult following so it's clever
you do this whole original piece showing
I can still do original material but
link it back to the cult fans of
unbreakable that way you're getting all
the audio here's a brilliant marketing
maneuver my opinion wheels and
storytelling maneuver like it was really
really maneuver on his end yeah I think
yeah that worked out really well not by
far that's like the best franchise
announcement I've seen a long time yeah
because it didn't get in the way of the
movie hell until the very end when it
becomes yeah it wasn't revealed till
after opening weekend when people on the
internet started really talking about it
yeah totally and that was like in and of
itself that was a special moment not
only is the movie pretty good and
interesting but also like you managed to
take one of the most kind of trite
things we do now which is set up
franchises and do it in a way where it
caught everybody off guard and got
people really excited and like felt like
a special moment you know yeah totally
especially because unbreakable and split
are two very different mood out totally
visually everything about it are very
varied I mean one film focusing on a
hero and other comes focusing on a bag
yeah now so you got to in completely
different films and it connected
that as a surprise twist is one of the
most brilliant things they could have
done hey I mean I wanted don't get me
wrong like as much as I think he should
do one more film and do the split and
breakable crossover film I'm splittable
is what some people call as much as I
want to see that done I would still
wanted to do one more film first and
then see the crossover I think that
would make the crossover even more
exciting actually if he did one more
film that was really good and then he
does the crossover yeah yeah cuz then
we'll have our full confidence receipt
yeah totally yeah it would be [ __ ]
awesome and I mean I thought it was fair
this stuff that they pointed out - even
though I'm night Shyamalan is back among
our good graces and it's nice to see
that everyone's mostly excited for that
like yeah I'm happy with this goodwill
again but he does have some things to
tighten up you know his movies even the
good ones have those clunky dialogue
moments I don't mind a clunky dialogue
at times them yeah I kind of fit with
the tone of what I was those scenes like
with the dad gave me the wood and dry
delivery I'm like I kind of thought he
was want me to death
there even that line that lady was
saying about the buffalo wings I thought
was funny it's like it's weird it like
because it is to me they do not so much
the Debbie I like the buffalo wings of
like it does read is a little cheesy but
I feel like there's a cheese in his
style somewhere like I feel like those
moments are when he's having some fun
and they don't especially in the better
movies they rarely rub me the wrong way
yeah like they're they're not true flaws
well because I think that the direction
M night Shyamalan was saying was films
like the visitings what is he wants to
make sure this audience is entertained
you know I feel like some films prior to
the visit
even before airbender it seemed like he
was just way too serious and exam
pretentious and just like so was
self-involved in his parking stuff
because that's what's weird about the
happening - and that's what's weird
about with the other one now after after
earthy as like they're very we had a
very somber and even the village was
going down that territory at the time
you know like I like the village but it
does kind of go down that territory yeah
and with the visiting slit it's like oh
he wants it he's really making sure
these are entertaining film
yeah so as long as he keeps that in mind
I feel like it'll be he'll keep doing a
great job like it's a good blend of
taking your work seriously but also
making sure your audience is being
entertained throughout what I'm really
holding in the water something like oh
man well my main hope is that you know
split unbreakable crossover break in act
3 if it turns out this is all happening
during the half and they got to put down
their differences in [ __ ] kill some
trees now be vonda be fantastic yeah all
right guys well John I have to jet to a
pretty important meeting right now we're
running a little late cuz I wanted to
shoot this 105 we got to be there 1:30
okay we got to get going subscribe to
the real rejects reason subscribe to
screen junkies reasons to Gerry on
Twitter and Instagram social media
manager of Blum House and the real
rejects that this meeting goes well
we'll have another announcement video
for you goodbye